[Musique]
gaming Twilight
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous on appelle pas rentrer chez nous on
n'appelle pas à rentrer chez nous après
le 14 après la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel mais au contraire ce
n'est pas neuf vieux politiciens qui
n'ont jamais bossé de leur vie qui vont
nous dire quoi faire c'est la loi et les
légitimes à passer ou pas mais ça sera à
la rue d'imposer le retrait de cette loi
et bien c'est des cons si ils
apprenaient à bosser ça sera autre chose
mais ta photo moi j'ai commencé à bosser
il y a 62 ans je suis à la retraite
maintenant mais je l'ai mérité et j'ai
bossé pendant 47 ans à l'hôpital voilà
mon petit j'aime pas Macron je ne
comprends pas bien c'est pour la
question mais c'est l'avantable on est
dans un pays lamentable alors oui il y a
des gens qui ont pas de sous ça c'est
vrai ça c'est un problème mais qu'on
manifeste pour des gens qu'on parle de
sous ça ça vaut le coup